hello
good evening and welcome everybody thank
you so much for joining us
in this live stream panel discussion
as you probably know as you can see down
below i'm susie from design anthology
and it's been a real pleasure for us to
partner with the design singapore
council on their groundbreaking visions
of the future exhibition
the exhibition has been running since
december last year
and had a physical and an online
component
so tonight's talk is entitled how can
design
change behaviour and as the title
suggests
it's going to be a discussion very much
around
behavioral design and i think we're
going to be
touching on some really interesting
topics
uh joining me tonight on the panel um
our guest
speakers first of all two young
designers who are
dialing in from singapore and that is
paul yoon roo
and kevin chan and their work
is part of the visions of the future
exhibition
and the two of them their work that is
part of the exhibition very much
addresses human behaviour and their
designs
are addressing different issues in
relation to that
joining kevin and yunru tonight is
uh fiona meehan who's a registered
psychologist
and the chief innovation director of
make studio
who's uh also in melbourne and
lee foo who is the executive director
and partner of uh uv architecture
and he's based in shenzhen so thank you
all for joining me
um i think this is going to be a really
interesting discussion
so without further ado let's get started
i think
for those of you who are watching there
is an opportunity
to type in questions so please do that
we'll have
i think a little bit of time at the end
for a q a
um and we'd love to hear some questions
from you so
let's get started um my first question
which is directed at each of you uh is
about the role of design in creating
positive change specifically behavioral
change
in the world and and how if at all do we
see
that change over to you fiona i think
that um
design has a huge potential um to change
um or influence behavior um and i guess
the key word is about influencing
behavior positive for positive change
rather than
making the behaviors itself so i think
um if we think about behavioral design
it's about
creating a choice architecture um that
will help people make changes
and um already there's a lot of examples
of where
um behavioral design is doing that so
for example um if you
um for countries that opt in for organ
donation
um there's a whole heap more people that
will actually um
actually will donate their organs than
for countries where you have to actually
opt in
to donate organs um embedding
affordances in designs
um if you're thinking about
re sustainability behaviours
there's lots of gamifications you can do
having clear rubbish bins all of those
sorts of things
there's a whole heap of really positive
things that you can do and and design
has a huge role to play there
but i think moving forward in the future
because
design also has the potential to um
create not so positive behavior
there's going to be a lot more um
emphasis on
how um how we actually look at the role
of the designer in creating the change
so the shift will be on
um making sure that the designers are
really clear on
you know what positive design and
positive change actually means
that people have the choices to make the
changes that that we're looking for
um and it's it's done in an ethical way
thanks fiona there's
a lot of really great touch points there
um lee foo i might ask you to
follow up on that given your background
in architecture
what role do you think design plays in
creating positive change
my point is that design of behavior
has been a critical um
creator of our culture of any cultures
especially like china is a long
with a really long history whether you
realize
or not a lot of our behavior were
designed
for thousands of years for example like
the confucius teaching
when you first enroll your school you
have to vote your teachers
and you have to show your respection
to the um to the confucius teaching
and that kind of thing is actually
definitely helping the society to pay a
lot of more attention
education and give the teachers
a really high status in this society
uh i think the by just
going to the teacher uh this is a very
long
tradition of the society i think it is a
good example
of how this behavior design can shape a
culture
i think the similar
idea uh can actually be
used in a lot of the future uh society
to improve uh whatever
the the value should be
put at so that'll that'll be my
point but what it is is
for our future discussion i think uh i
think you've raised some really
interesting points there thank you
um i think let's ask uh yunru
what do you see as the role of design
um in creating positive change
in the future so i think for me
the role of design here is more to help
understand
and empathize and complement existing
user behavior
so for example a project that was
showcased in
the vision of the future exhibition my
project in this case um it was not
really designed
to drastically change the behavior of my
user
but rather tapping on phone memories or
experiences and instinctive behavior to
trigger their memory
if we can perhaps go to
um kevin about your thoughts on the role
of design
and creating positive change and
translate weak signals or cues into
tangible
nudges that eventually challenge our
mental schemas
in order to
or act of succe in a positive way now
while the strategies
and methodologies we employ may change
depending on the circumstance
i doubt that the role of design would
change in the future
simply because design is a way of
thinking it's a frame of mind that
creatively interprets the situation
the context before suggesting an
appropriate point of action
i'd love for each of you to talk a bit
about your work in a recent project and
for
uh kevin and yunru that would be the
work
that's in the visions of the future
exhibition
and talk a bit about how you've tried to
shape or
change normal human behavior
via design a majority of my work focuses
on people and behavior change so in the
recent
exhibition i designed a collection of
probes focusing
on two areas first is safety and second
is hygiene
with of course the second theme being
more pronounced in a pandemic
now the first one which is safety i
designed sort of a complimentary fire
alarm system
it's called echo and leverages on the
tension
derived from a very large inflating
balloon
to drive action and to facilitate path
or wave fighting now this is because i
realized through research that fire
deaths
are often due to inaction rather than
panic so this is the first project
the second project looks into how we
uncover
the touch bases generally between 20-30
times
in a single hour and in fact this ritual
actually gives
germs and bacteria a free ride into our
bodies
so to combat or to think about that
i designed a piece of jewelry tighter
odor it is a ring
that uses our natural response to bad
odour
to discourage us from touching our faces
now
once you twist the ring apart you it
reveals a lightly saturated
ammonium sulphide core which is
associated with
uh bad eggs for example and it is only
detectable within range when you
draw your hand near to your face
um so therefore when we draw our hands
for close to our face our instinct will
tell us to keep our hands clear
now in the last design we understand
that
hand wash can be counter intuitive to
children
considering the fact that they spend
more time getting it dirty
so the question that i had was how then
can we encourage them to do so
and therefore i've designed soap tattoos
right which is essentially a set of
stickers with a soap facade
hiding a graphic motif that reveals
itself only when children apply water
and in doing so they get to wash their
hands uh fundamentally it appeals to the
children's
sense of curiosity and wonder thanks
kevin this
yeah there's some really interesting uh
behaviors
through there which i think is really
interesting so i'm curious to know kevin
what do you
think um as a designer
how deep of an understanding of
psychology do you think
designers need to have um when
when sort of pursuing a career in
industrial design do you think it's
really fundamental or do you think it
depends on
um the kinds of issues that you're
hoping to address in your work
well frankly speaking i would say
perhaps just deep enough so allow me to
explain
right so unlike psychologists or
psychiatrists
who have both breath and depth of
knowledge
in behavior in biology and the human
psyche
designers on the other hand delve deep
within a particular area
depending of the topic of interest and
the project that they undertake
so for example if we are trying to help
children with adhd
we try to understand the factors
or the stimulus that affect the
attention span so with that said of
course it will not hurt to have a basic
understanding of
for example sigmund freud's
psychoanalysis or have
some level of understanding of bs
skinner's theory of
operant conditioning which really
involves
the usage of rewards and punishment to
motivate
or to discourage a particular behavior
so
perhaps i would like to say is that
industrial designers
often operate in teams and we often
consult
psychologists as well right to obtain a
better understanding of the situation
before we synthesize and therefore we
can
translate these insights into much more
tangible yet grounded
positions so to your answer to answer
your question i would say it's just
enough
yeah that's um that's that's a great
answer
um is is anybody else out there can we
have we got any audio from any of the
other
susie i wonder if it would help um if i
talk to you a little bit about an
example of a project i've been working
on
um in in the area of behavior change
um as well as working for make studios i
also
work as chief eco innovation officer at
a social enterprise called street
um street helps young people who need a
hand with life skills and job readiness
training
in hospital hospitality and also
horticulture
but we're also really dedicated to
helping to create a healthy planet
so as part of that back in 2019 we ran a
campaign called september
so it's a bit different to some of the
amazing products that
some of the other panelists have talked
about a little while ago it was more
about
thinking about how could we change
sustainable behaviours
around reducing single-use coffee cups
in australia the average um usage of um
reusable cups
has been historically about five to
seven percent
and we wanted to actually change that up
quite a bit so
we created a campaign where we looked at
changing the environment first of all so
that was creating a cup loan scheme for
some of our cafes
that customers from the general public
access we also looked at closed loop
systems
in some of the buildings that we work in
where people could actually
take a cup and and keep it within the
building that they're in and somebody
would
collect it we also looked at
gamification
where we had some friendly rivalry
across different cafes
and we use tiny habits which is helping
people to
create little habits um that help them
remember their reusable cup
it's a methodology created by b.j fogg
who is um he's a behavioral scientist at
stanford university
um so we use that as well and we had a
goal of getting up to 33
um of reusable cups from our average of
about 17
and we managed to achieve that 33 that
was up until the pandemic um started and
we had to sort of
put that on hold for a bit but it was
actually really really
interesting to be able to test out our
nudges and
behavior design changes um in real life
and measure
how how effective they were you created
um last year um for design trusts
exhibition
in hong kong could you talk to us a
little bit about
last year we actually took part in this
um
[Music]
design exhibition in hong kong and we
designed a shared chopstick
the the reason is that we think uh
during the epidemic
not only in the epidemic but even before
the epidemic
uh chinese people used to
share their meals with chopsticks
and it's rather hard to
to push for the habit of the
using public or shared
chopsticks which means there's a
chopsticks that you only use for pick up
the meals from the table rather than put
in your mouth
and that is why a lot of
some stomach and digestion
diseases uh it has much higher
percentage
among chinese population um than the
other part of the city
of the world and this kobe 19 uh
epidemic only addressed the emergency
of uh really changing the behavior that
people are sitting around the table and
so there were a
very good efforts uh to
pushing around the uh
using a shared chopsticks
but we noticed that it's really hard to
push that and promote it
and because when you're sitting around
the table and the
the shared chopsticks is always
easy to be mixed up with your
uh your own chopsticks and it's really
hard
and embarrassing culturally to remind
your guests
to using it so we feel that
it'll probably be a better way to
guide people through a
more interesting way by putting a pair
of chopsticks
around the table and make it really
interesting
and attracting their attention that is
why we designed the uh
chopsticks samurai which will stand on a
table
rotating around with the dishes and
people can easily
uh pick up and targeting
the uh the meals and when you
when you use it it's very easy and
comfortable for you to put it back
and i think the uh the the exhibition
got a very good uh feedback and we are
actually
um uh commercializing it
and now uh we are starting to sell it
in hong kong and we are also
talking to some vendors in
within mainland china i think this again
i'll come back to my uh cultural issue
actually the behavior
is the essence of the culture sharing
around the table is the culture of
all chinese i think
ethnic group without giving up their
culture but uh by
carefully manipulate their
device of the behavior
will hopefully shape the uh society
uh in in a better future i think that
somehow uh answered the first question
uh susie has uh has
mentioned okay
yeah thank you for that um it's such a
a brilliant and simple solution to
um you know some need um
you know i think it's it's wonderful
what you've created and i wanted to
address
another question to you actually because
up until now
we've talked mostly about product design
and maybe some simple solutions
that um are divine eyes through
graphics or user interface but i also
wanted to talk about architecture
because
i think the spaces that we inhabit
also have the power to change our
behavior
and there was a study that i read about
just this week actually that the us
army did it was an experiment with four
model homes
and each of the behaviors of the
residents in those four homes
differed quite greatly now the four
homes
had very different energy ratings they
went from
uh very inefficient in terms of energy
usage
all the way to the other extreme of
highly efficient as in
zero use of energy now the surprising
outcome was
that zero use house
they the residents actually used the
most amount of power whereas
in the least energy efficient home
um they actually use the least amount of
power and the outcome of that was that
actually it was
human behavior that was the driver of
the energy usage the people living
in the energy efficient home the most
energy efficient home
um we're assuming that they could do
whatever they want and they almost
forgot about their behavior and their
habits
and we're wasting a lot of energy
because of that whereas
in the least energy efficient home they
were much more conscious of their
behavior and their energy usage and
therefore used
the least amount um now you know lifu i
would love to have you
talk a little bit about how we can
create spaces
and buildings that can change the
behavior of the inhabitants
in a positive way that can you know
obviously have a great
impact on the environment would you like
to comment
on that
yeah sure i'll be happy to uh to comment
that
issue because after all i'm an architect
i deal with buildings much more than
i deal with the uh the the devices
or industrial products uh definitely uh
i think the weird thing is that whenever
you buy an iphone or you buy a product
you come with introduction of how to use
it
but you never got an introduction of how
to use your home and
you just don't you just don't get it and
you just
use it whatever ways as you like
and people think that it's they are
entitled
to use their abilities or use their home
as
whatever they wish and so i think
there is always a differentiations
between how
the buildings were designed and how they
are intended
to be designed to be used versus
how the users actually
use it um so i i think there will be
um like in your example there will be
definitely a very
surprising or unsurprising outcome
because the uh the central
elements of a building is actually its
user
uh how you use it if you just throw your
iphone into the water and definitely
you know you can cannot complain about
uh it it will get uh wrecked right but
when you are using a building i think
it's the same way uh
so i think the um architecture
uh well no some so many times
architecture being considered
to be something that um
um distance from the users
people addressing on the how beautiful
it is and how
advanced the technical and used
and to their users
they might change
their future usage of their beauty
and as a another
if we extend this example to the city to
all the other buildings i think really
it's important to
educated people of
how the building could be correctly used
and also on the other hand the design
has to be more inclusive of
people's behavior rather than design
in in a very ideal way
but ignoring the diversity of
human being and all the deflections of
human behavior so i think this is a
double we will have to take care of
you've raised so many great points there
i mean i could not agree more i would
love to see buildings come with a user
manual that's
uh that's such a great idea um i wonder
fiona do you have uh any comments on
what leaf just said
yeah i i agree with um lifu i i couldn't
agree more about the the manual idea as
well and
i would add to that um i guess when i
think about um
the designing of spaces to help with
from an environmental perspective
you know um people for any behavior to
happen it's a combination of motivation
and ability and there's also the
interplay between
you know cognitive um conscious
conscious things that you're aware of
and unconscious things that just uh um
are actually unconscious things that you
do and um
in designing spaces there's obviously
the environment
and there's a great um a person in
australia called
jost baker who has created an amazing
environmentally friendly house
and it actually includes everything from
having yabbies in the back
in the backyard they've got sort of a
way that you can fish your own food and
it's very very environment
environmentally friendly so it would
almost be impossible not to actually
behave in a way that would be really
positive for the environment
but when you've got when you've got
choice there and conscious choice
sometimes i think that it's really
important to actually integrate
elements um that are available to people
from a conscious perspective and
it kind of touches on the idea of the
user manual um that leafy talked about
um in that if you could actually start
to provide information
to people within an environment so if
you have a device
and you're able to actually see how much
energy it uses
and also potentially see how much energy
other houses are using so that you can
actually compare yourself
um to other environments those are
potentially ways that you could look at
um
you know potentially creating an
environment where you're helping people
make good choices
and you mentioned gamification a little
bit earlier fiona do you think that that
could potentially come into
this yes i do
i definitely think gamification um
there's actually some really there's a
person called peter hershberg who who
did a whole bunch
of um gamification in i think he did
some in singapore actually as well
where he looked at using ar so you could
actually
hold up your device and see the energy
consumption on different buildings
and he was able to successfully show
that if you could actually see how
well your building was doing compared to
other buildings in terms of energy
efficiency
it actually um or energy usage i should
say
he found that it actually made a
difference to people's consumption
so there are ways that it has been used
before and
i know it might seem that it would only
suit one you know
maybe people who are more tech savvy but
there are also ways of including
gamification that are very analog as
well
um where you actually start for people
you start to design things so that
people can see
um you know what other people are doing
and they can start to compare themselves
and have friendly competitions
yeah i imagine the world would be a very
different place if it became
fun to save energy and to um to do other
things that benefited the environment
um you know we've had we've touched on a
number of points but we haven't actually
really
kind of gotten to the covert 19 thing
yet which is obviously
um i think the context to the exhibition
of visions of the future
uh and and kevin two of your works
specifically relate to the pandemic
one not so specifically and you
issues that you've addressed in your
work existed before
clover19 but perhaps were you know maybe
exacerbated or accelerated because
of the pandemic um i i think i'd like to
talk a bit about covert 19 and how it's
um or actually i wouldn't i'm tired of
talking about it i'm sure everybody is
but we should we should discuss it
um i think we should talk about how it's
changing our behaviors
um and which new or different behaviours
you've noticed
within yourself and perhaps um your
community
um kevin do you want to maybe if you can
hear me apart
from sanitation core bit 19 has
definitely changed the way
we communicate and the way we conduct
business so for example during the very
early stages
of circuit breaker in singapore
there was a noticeable increase in the
creation of
online businesses and entrepreneurial
endeavors as well as contactless
transactions
of course i think the change that i see
myself i see in myself
and some of my colleagues is that we
start to pay an extra attention
to our health and exercise
while the initial thought is that
exercising outdoors give
us an excuse right during the circuit
breaker or during the lockdown
the term that is used in some other
countries right that nudge eventually
motivated the formation of healthy
habits
which tend to stick after about 30 days
or so
and then people start to continue to
exercise so that is something that
i saw right the change i saw in myself
even after
the lockdown or the circuit breaker was
lifted
yeah interesting what about you uh yoon
roo
maybe for me i will talk a bit about how
kobe kind of influenced the way
we interact with our environment because
clearly this
is the period where um it's encouraged
as little physical interaction as
possible with our environment
and we became more conscious
about everything we touched when we are
in public places
and to me i feel a sense of touch is
kind of an important role in the way we
perceive our environment
so i find it becoming more
like an interesting challenge to
consider if there is any design
alternative that can serve or make up
for the void
created by our reliance on touch and
through my project i also realized that
the physical sensation
and physical contact with things and
people strongly influence the way we
remember things
and the way events are captured in our
memory
and as such like as we are forced to
reduce interaction with others and
things around us
how will we remember the world um
change and also in the future will
certain things kind of be
a bit um obsolete because for example
like will people in the future still
use or remember red packet because
especially
um like for this situation now the way
young powers are being encouraged
during chinese new year i think it's
interesting to also consider like
which culture will weaken and strengthen
or even evolve as a result
you were just saying about the uh the
differences between what you'd observed
in china and the us do you want to
continue
yeah i definitely think this is a
perfect example of how the behavior
shaped the society in
uh certain circumstances and
i think culturally chinese people are
much more
disciplined and following the um
whatever the authority's direction is
and they stay as they stand home
and they keep on the mask and
then when i landed in the uh los angeles
i feel like
you know i'm the only person
paranoid and
so i stayed there and since nothing
happened
to everybody else and i even though
the the news channels
talk about how many people died but
since nobody really cares then i
come back to china and i you know i stay
there since then i feel like
in this kind of circumstances uh the
behavior of individuals
following the instruction
is much more better off than
just follow your heart so
so in china actually we we are almost
back to normal uh
for most of the rest of that year but it
seems that in the
uh in us the uh they're starting to
turn back to normal after the vaccine
comes out
so i think that definitely is an
example of how the behavior behavior
of individuals can shape the
this situation of the whole uh society
um well again that that's about culture
i think i believe different countries
have
different cultures and uh
part of them is somehow embedded
in everybody's behavior so
um yeah that's my observation
i really couldn't agree more i had been
in hong kong
uh and landed in australia last march
the beginning of design week
and agree i completely agree i think i
was the only one wearing a face mask and
was quite shocked to see how um
seemingly blase australia was about all
of this so fiona i'd love to hear your
thoughts about some
you know changing changes in behavior in
australia
since and through the pandemic have you
noticed anything specific that you'd
like to share
well as you as you've just said um we
were very slow um to get off the mark
with wearing masks in australia
um and and as well we were getting
advice i guess
from medical experts to tell us that it
was advisable not to wear masks
and it was only um it took quite some
time for us to really get on board and
understand
how important they were um but like many
people
while i thought that it would be a good
idea to wear a mask i also
know i struggled personally going to the
supermarket for example
thinking on the one hand it would
actually be really good idea to wear a
mask
and on the other hand you know wondering
if i'm going to bump into a neighbor who
thinks that i'm just going overboard
with when the advice was very clear
and at the cafes that we have as well we
had to start to think about what we were
going to do and we decided to
implement masks mask wearing in our
cafes
but this was before the government had
mandated them and
fortunately very very shortly after we'd
made that decision
um the victorian government mandated
them and i think that actually
that was a tipping point for us in
australia i think or in victoria i
should say
um the people started to gladly wear
them um
a large proportion of people started to
gladly wear them when it became
you know something that was that was
mandated um so it really did change
things and i know for myself
i actually um knowing that it's really
important to have a good uber rating i
would
normally be reluctant to sort of
challenge too much when it comes to
being in an uber
um but with with covert i um felt it was
really important to
make sure and insist that the driver was
wearing a mask as well as myself
um and also to have the window wide open
and to get the ventilation happening
so i think we've come a long way in
victoria i would say some of our other
states are less
less some uh inclined to wear mask and
it's a lot to do with the gov
the government and policy i think
yeah absolutely but i think melbourne's
having gone through one of the longest
lockdowns in the world
um have probably had a great deal of
their behaviors changed
um whether they like it or not um
so i think i'm going to move to our last
question i know that we've everyone's
been incredibly patient and persistent
this evening um with these uh
intermittent tech issues so i don't want
to keep everyone too late
um so my last question for each of you
is about you know what you see the
future of
behavioral design um being where that
might move to and whether there may be
any
ethical issues um i know fiona you had
perhaps some thoughts on that
um and or if there was anything that you
were working on that might be of
interest that is incorporating
behavioural design
so maybe fiona if you'd like to talk a
bit maybe about the ethics
of behavioral design yeah sure
um yes i think um ethics is becoming as
i mentioned at the very beginning
really really important um and people
are becoming way more aware of that
there's um
i don't know if people have heard of the
the agitator and designer mike montero
who
mentions that you know as designers we
have
an obligation or we're responsible we
take responsibility for what we design
and the effect of what we design and i
guess three areas that are really
important for that is to think about um
the goals um that we're trying to
achieve through designing
um and making behavior change is it for
the actual person
or is it for um somebody else um for the
general public
or is it actually manipulating people so
um in thinking about what are nudgies is
it um and i know richard thaler talks
about that as
nudge versus sludge sludge being when
it's actually manipulating people
and it's a very fine line there
sometimes between what is actually
helping somebody and what is um what is
actually
you know being manipulative and i guess
it really is in my mind about
doing what's helpful for the person and
the general public
um the second thing is autonomy do we by
creating
um nudges and behavioral interventions
are we actually um are we doing things
that people are unaware of
um and taking away their autonomy and um
are we also
sort of um reducing their their ability
to think for themselves in the long run
you know if everything becomes automatic
and
a nudge does that mean that people are
left with them they don't get as much
practice as they should
um in making their own decisions about
things and the third thing is the effect
you know are we
um actually when when we're creating
behavior change are we actually getting
the impact that we want
are the nudges that we're putting in
place effective uh
and also are they um creating unintended
negative consequences
so an example of that might be though
exercise trackers
where um you know they're intended to
help motivate people and get people to
exercise more but there's actually a lot
of evidence that an unintended
consequence of
exercise trackers is that if people
don't meet their 10 000 steps a day or
whatever goals that they have
it can actually um they actually sort of
lose motivation and stop exercising as
much
as one example
that's a lot of food for thought there
thank you for sharing that with us
uh i wonder lifu do you have anything to
add is there anything
uh you know aside from creating a user's
manual for buildings or cities
is there anything else that you'd like
to see happen in the future in the realm
of behavioral design or anything that
you're working on that's incorporating
that
yeah yeah
uh i think the uh the behavior design
uh can be guided on either end
uh ethnic uh ethnic issue definitely is
part of
the bottom lines we are talking about
here
and i'm doing a lot actually in my
uh architectural career uh i'm designing
a lot of
uh retail or the mixed-use projects
i work for developers a lot and
i think some of the behavioral
design can be used in making the city a
better place
and make it more
a bit more energy but at the same time
on the other
hand uh many times the uh
behavioral design were abused uh
to become so perfect uh center
and to make people addictive to certain
behavior
in order to make money out of it and i
think
uh especially in uh
commercial world uh and in the
gaming world and in the
gaming industry so many people and so
many especially young kids
just cannot escape from
the addiction to their
electric gadgets and i think that's a
perfect example of
how behavior design
been abused in order to
trade profit for the enterprise
and for the capital um so i think the
architect
i think on the on one hand we were still
uh trying to make the um uh
behavioral design a good tool uh to
energize people and energize the city
um and other hand actually i think we uh
um we have this responsibility
to make a real world more attractive
to the young people and the kids so that
we are actually competing with
in terms of architecture and the
physical space we are competing
with the uh virtual gadgets
um we are trying to create more
interesting places for
people to hang out and to chat and to
meet person by person rather than uh
addictive to the virtual world uh one
project actually i'm working on we have
just finished the
server well you we used re recycled
uh inner tire from the um
of the rubber inner tire to create
jumping beds
as a playground for kids
and it was quite success successful it's
uh
it's a installation in uh
uab uh shenzhen piano
uh in shanghai um
and the the exhibitions are over and
we will actually uh
cooperate with some other camping sites
and
some other uh entrepreneurs to make them
available for the campers and for the
families and
kids and i think by making the physical
world more interesting and more
attractive
uh there's one way that we can do
to compete with the
addiction to the commercial
and to the electric gadgets
i think uh that's the thing we are
trying to test right now
um well i love the sound of that i
you know i think that that's such a
wonderful field of inquiry to make the
real world
so great that we don't need to be lost
in our phones
thanks kevin do you want to share
anything with us well i guess
more about the work that i'm currently
pursuing right
i am currently looking into how
the usage of very simple pelter
technology
essentially it's just a surface and when
you run a current through it you can
drop the temperature of that surface
or you can increase the temperature of
that surface
and i'm using that as a basis to conduct
a simple research to understand
how by introducing that temperature
change in our ears
we are able to actually change our
perception of heat and therefore help us
better cope
in heat waves which is definitely a
phenomenon that's
getting much more frequent and much more
intense
i guess another sort of the project that
i'm looking into it's
sort of changing the perceptions of what
people have or food waste
so for example i'm currently looking at
cosmetically filtered food produced
and the potential applications of this
would produce
so either as cosmetics for example um
it may sound ironic but it is in a way a
poetic interpretation of
beauty and how
we sort of acknowledge the fact that you
know these are discarded
but eventually we are able to use it for
ourselves to
make our looks better to make it look
better right um
i guess the last point is regarding the
future
of vehicle design on the more optimistic
note
i would say that the basis of behavioral
design will definitely extend
beyond just looking at people but rather
also at other living things
and our environment i believe that
you'll be used as a tool
to help us decode the world that we know
so that we can better anticipate
the changes to come so just to give an
example
understanding the behavior changes in
bees can help to predict crop harvests
right since bees are very
key players that help to pollinate food
crops so i believe there would be that
shift to
having behavior design just starting
with people to extending that scope to
studying
other living things thanks kevin they
all sound really interesting and i think
you know anything in particular related
to global warming is is only going to be
a very
um fruitful field of inquiry while we're
waiting for yunru to come back
online i'd really like to encourage all
of you that are watching tonight to
visit the visions of the future
exhibition it will be online until the
end of march
um kevin and nuru are two of
several young designers from singapore
whose work is on show in the exhibition
and you may know the website already
that's probably
how you're watching the live stream but
in case it's not
please visit the website it is
visionsoftthefuture.sg
and yeah please read up each of the
designers are
uh equally accomplished and thoughtful
um and i'm sure have a very bright
future ahead of each of them
um yunru are you there
so please tell us what you're working on
and any fields of inquiry
that you've got coming up
okay so i think for me i'm more looking
to see how
my project will evolve so i'm planning
to
see how i could push my project into
like an open source website
in which people could download and 3d
print the device in the future
making it more accessible for everyone
or even the users
to be able to contribute to the constant
development of the product um
[Music]
yeah so i'm also interested to explore
and focus on
creating more meaningful designs that
suit smaller productions and
um how it can diversifies into many
alternative manufacturing processes that
are able to fit the needs of
niche market rather than mass producing
for all
sounds great well you know i'm sure that
i speak for
all of us in that we're very much
looking forward to seeing what both of
you have
um coming up next so i think that is all
that we have time for this evening i
want to say thank you to each of you for
your patience and your perseverance and
for everyone that's watching for your
patients as well and i hope you've all
stayed
um online and and watched us through to
the end
um so thank you a big thank you to paul
yunroo
kevin cham fiona mian and lifu for
joining us and for your time
for your insights and your expertise
it's been a really interesting
discussion despite
the technical difficulties of uh
connecting
four countries three countries
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
all